hearing someone like you who's a role
models so many different people of
different walks of life and everything
it will just help people so much I hope
so even though a year and a half ago I
never thought I'd be in this position
I'm just I'm just buzzing that I kind of
overcome it
welcome back to grammar with me Josh
Smith and today we are joined by a
legend Harry Edwards how are you thank
you good very good I mean you're
stepping out on your own for the first
time mr. burger campaign how's that feel
yeah it's been so good today I have a
best ever really fun how's it feel
stepping away from your light security
blanket of the girls would you say at
first I'm not gonna lie was i but yeah
it's been really good because one thing
that I really expect you feel recently
you've opened up about your anxiety and
like your post ballot was so powerful
and it was really moving and it's really
incredible to see someone like you using
your position for the greater good and
to also speak to your fans which is
really incredible how cathartic was that
experience for you when it first started
happening to me like it felt so like it
had never happened to anyone before I
can't explain it it was almost because I
didn't know what was happening we were
preparing for the glory days to her yeah
and I always have many breakdowns during
tour because learning that much
choreography and learning everything I
miss a lot it's intense it's so intense
it it's sold mentally and physically
draining although it's fun it's hard
work I don't know if it's come with
being in the industry and knowing that
people are constantly looking at me and
constantly you want a piece of me or
there might be a pop somewhere or
something like that I don't know what
triggered it but it just happened when I
was going through the physical attacks
and the panic attacks because I think
I've always had anxiety I just don't
think it's ever been triggered in a way
that I'd become like a physical attack
so when it first started happening to me
it was just so scary because I didn't
know what was going on I was ringing
doctors I was ringing everybody like I'm
dying
I've just had a heart attack and
survived it like I thought I was
genuinely there was something wrong with
me and then the reason I never wanted to
speak about it before is because every
time someone said oh I've got a bit of
anxiety or I have a bit of this it would
trigger it and then it would happen it
was almost like speaking about it made
it kind of come out it was like this
devil that was terrified of me but it's
just your mind kind of
I guess trying to prepare yourself for
something bad that's gonna happen but
it's just odd
I don't know so what helped me the most
it sounds awful not saying that I wanted
other people to be experienced in it but
like I looked into it and I noticed that
le golden came out and said that she had
bad anxiety and she couldn't get the car
to the studio and I read that phone
cotton was like on the motorway in her
car and she had a physical attack and it
was terrifying and it starts and it
started to kind of make me feel a bit
more normal yeah I'm a completely
different person into what I was here
and a half core so when I put that on
social media I like I just thought I'm
just gonna be honest about it so I'm
just really glad I did it because I do
think social media has kind of taken
over everyone's lives right now like
especially the young'uns because the
crazy thing is we do live in very
anxious times because of social media
but the amazing thing is is you view
social media as a great force for great
good and you're talking about it's
helping other people but what is your do
you have a love hate relationship with
social media of course on one hand it's
the best thing ever we can go online
every day talk to our fans we're really
close have this connection with them but
then on the other hand you go on
Instagram and you see people live in
these ideal lifestyles and people have
been perfect 24/7 and you look at it and
you think well why don't I look like
that and why don't I have a private jet
every day and why don't I have a Bentley
I'm parked outside and it starts to
really mess with your head and you start
to feel like you're not good enough and
it makes you feel a bit [ __ ] and like
it's trying to differentiate what's real
and what's not and social media a lot of
the time it isn't real and it's great
like we were saying that you are using
your platform to talk about the anxiety
and things like that because then you
can talk about a journey and then people
can almost go on it with you as well and
then that shows it's a positive thing
and not a negative thing as well because
when you think about that journey about
the journey you've gone from with
anxiety from like the start till now how
has your self-confidence grown in order
to take steps to overcome it weirdly
when I first started experience in the
panic attacks
I developed a fear of being on my own so
like still now it's a lot better than it
was but when it first started happened
and I kept seeing like if I have a panic
attack and I'm on my own what do I do
I've got nobody to kind of reason with
me and I can't rationalize it in my head
and I can't make sense of it at the time
so if I haven't got anybody with me what
do i do so like it got to the point
where my mom was kind of coming to the
studio with me she was driving to work
with me because I just couldn't get in a
car on my own I'd be in a car for two
seconds and I would like to turn it
around I have to go home like it would
freak me out I just wouldn't be able to
leave the house without feeling normal
and like getting the train like even now
my like my boyfriend lives in Manchester
service he he plays for Liverpool so
when he moved it was just like it was
crap and then once this started
happening I thought oh god this is
horrendous I couldn't I still can't get
the train on my own like it freaks me
out I feel really close to for Vic
I just feel uneasy but like obviously it
was horrendous at one point and I
couldn't even if my mom was like I'm
going to the shop for a bottle milk I'd
sweat like I'd sweat and I'd panic and
I'd be like please don't leave me on my
own because the second you leave that
door I'm gonna have a panic attack and
I'm on my own like what do I do and then
it got to the point I was like right man
you got the shop right and take your
phone and then as soon as you've been
gone and I start to feel a bit funny
like I'll ring you and I did it I did
the same with Alex's mom and Wendy she's
been incredible like it was Christmas
time and she was like I'm gonna go walk
the dog and I'll be gone for like 2
minutes and then I'll take my phone and
if you need me ring and I can run back
and I was like ok and I try and stay as
long as I could without ringing up but
I'd be like shaking it was so weird and
she would like see if find something to
keep your mind occupied and like do like
paint so my mom got me these little
dolls I started paying in the mobile
said she like shaking there's thinking
don't write now don't write now you're
an adult come on you can do it and they
think battling with your own like you're
yourself it's just weird
but the more I did it the better it got
my best friend Ellie / cousin she moved
in with me and it's obviously helped and
now she can go out with her friends and
I'm cool like I'm alright on my own like
it sounds ridiculous but it's almost
like I needed to be babysat for a long
time and I still struggle now like I
wouldn't be able to just go somewhere on
my own like get on the train and go
somewhere on my own UPS I just can't do
that anymore it from when I look back
now to this kind of weird wobble that I
had I never thought I'd be where I am
now because I don't never thought there
was a way out and then I thought you
can't live your life like that how am I
going to have a career how am I going to
get on stage and perform how am I gonna
meet the fans how am I gonna do any of
the stuff that I love doing if I don't
leave the house so as I doing a step by
step like learning to walk again it was
just weird once I get out the house a
bit more my mom didn't have to come to
work with me anymore and then I was fine
then I started travelling on my own I
can get in a car and go to Manchester
now and I'm fine yeah and I still a bit
uneasy about the Train yeah I mean it is
what it is
but yeah it's kind of it's just fine in
coping mechanisms I'm constantly getting
better I'm constantly not letting it
defeat me and it's just one step at a
time I think I think we need to remember
one a journey right yes and I think the
thing you said in the post we said I've
been in a relationship with my mind for
25 years is such a powerful statement
because we need to realise what actually
a relationship with ourselves there we
are
but I don't think there's enough of that
like we don't realise that I mean like
all let's work on my relationship myself
what are the coping mechanisms for you
my dog yeah oh my god hacci is literally
my son at you like it's Ricky as well I
know when everybody's out if I've got
Hachi I'm cool like I'm fine I've got my
little mate
I'm good he keeps me saying talking to a
stranger like that helps massively
speaking to someone who has no idea
what's going on in your life you just
let it all out and it's the best feeling
in the world like therapy for me helped
hugely and it's amazing you can sit here
and not be ashamed about it as well no
so I think a lot of people feel that
they go see a therapist they're like oh
yeah why do you think that I don't know
because I thought if I tell everybody
I've been to therapy they're gonna think
I'm nuts at one point I thought my mom
was gonna have to seminary
somewhere because I was having these
dark thoughts I was thinking differently
than the way I would I'm a very positive
outgoing bubbly sunshine person so when
this happened it was like from that to
that and I was thinking dark thoughts
that are that was freaking me out and
then the more I thought about it it
would freak me out even more
I just think even if you're feeling a
bit down at work or you're feeling a bit
down about things that are going on in
your family or just anything it's nice
to speak to people yeah it's nice to
talk if you've got a friend or a teacher
or just anyone who you know will listen
for five minutes it's just the best
thing ever to let it out it's very
empowering as well people need to
realize that that anything that you can
take on to meet you stuff feel better it
can be a very empowering experience for
you and you go for it and there's a
really interesting thing that I saw the
other day where someone said if you tell
your head to stop doing something it
won't because if you tell you it's just
like an organ in your body because if
you tell your heart to stop beating and
waiting to stop beating yeah that's so
true yeah when I heard that was like oh
my god this makes so much sense because
we spend so much time beating ourselves
up trying to be like line stopped doing
this whereas if you go through the
motions are there yes sit down and
actually theorize yeah actually helps so
much yeah totally totally I'm a human
but gonna go through things we're going
to go through hard times and hard
periods of our life um and it's not
going to be an easy ride all the time
and I think that's what we forget again
social media it seems that way people
think that people are live in these
idyllic lives and it's not and there's
bumps in the road and there's gonna be
and I think that's that's life I've seen
you go through so many different stages
of your life like in the public area and
being going through pipe five at times
at the same time like you were going for
this anxiety at the same time as you
probably haven't go out do interviews
and perform and be happy like how did
you learn to like treasure your private
life in the very public world and work
on yourself away from this public world
oh that's hard yeah that is really hard
I think sometimes when you're in this
industry you kind of have to be you have
to be the actress
it does suck that you can't show your
emotion 24/7 because you have to be on
you have to be on the camera have to be
ready super doing and like you can be
heartbroken and just want to get in bed
and throw the quilt over your head and
never come out for it and eat ice cream
and be miserable but instead you have a
performance to prepare for and
interviews to do and sometimes it's it's
better because I think if I didn't have
work at the time that all of like the
anxiety was going on I wouldn't have
went like if I didn't have three other
girls to think about and be strong for
and all the fans that wanted to see the
show be the best it could possibly be I
don't think I would have came back to
work well I think you're just so
incredible at your hair right now
staying there because it's honestly like
I can't imagine having to do that like
we all have moments when we're like
right we have to cope because of other
people yeah but when you're doing it for
like millions of fans that can be so
daunting and you've actually got through
it and I just think you're amazing you
actually are this is why I've got so
much respect for you girls because
you've done so much incredible stuff to
help people and you haven't just sat
there and you could very easily have sat
here today and like brushed over all the
things you've gone through but anyone
who watches this is really gonna help
them like I go for anxious moments we
all go for anxious moments and like
hearing someone like you who's a role
model so many different people different
walks of life and everything it will
just help people so much I hope so yeah
and it well and also even just like for
instance when you you went through and
you just came out about your freckles
and you were like yeah I'm gonna I just
want to be really proud about that
that's another amazing thing you've done
as well I think and I think you should
take the time to pat yourself on the
back because you've honest you've helped
so many people and you can see that in
your fan base yeah I hope so
that's why I did it so even though a
year and a half ago I never thought I'd
be in this position I'm just I'm just
buzzing that kind of
yeah but saying you should be you should
be passing by and I do know that thing
you said about the freckles as well
because I think we're living in such
like a pressured beauty industry still
how is your relationship with beauty
industry change do you think when I was
younger I remember I was in the
playground and we were playing catch she
kisses one of the boys was like yeah
let's play catch kisses and I was like
okay and then I was thinking really hot
someone catches a big first smooch yes
and I ran and I looked behind and there
wasn't one person chasing me there were
all after Nicola and I remember thinking
and I remember one of the boys was I
don't kiss her she's well frankly you
know I remember thinking what is wrong
with my freckles and I hated them and I
went home and I was like man I'm
thinking of getting a skin peel and she
was like wow and I would say you know
surely they can peel off your skin and
put new skin on it so what is wrong with
you why are you saying this and I was
like because the boys want to kiss me
because apparently I'm too freckly and
she was like that is nonsense she was
like you wait till they're all want to
kiss you know my mom what was the new
idea stir like it gives you a complex
like an even masks are like grown-up
being in the dressing rooms getting
changed from all the other girls and I
had this big scar my stomach and I just
like it's just a lot when you're a kid
you think it's the end of the world
you'd think that if you've got freckles
or it's something you're interested
about like scars and everything like
that like it's it's it's renders it's
the end of the world why can it be
normal why I kind of have a normal
stomach and as you get older you think
yeah I think it's pretty quirky you know
like I love freckles I'm like this in
the Sun no try to get more because I
just loved them and whereas when I was a
kid it was different but I just think
when you're a kid everything's 10 times
worse you worry about the silliest
things like Doria so I think age
definitely helped me I've always said
you can't please everyone if I'm trying
to please people why do I have to do
something that makes me unhappy like
when lots of foundation to make my skin
look flawless
when people are still gonna say like
[ __ ] and they're gonna say why she went
too much makeup so I may as well just be
myself and then well I think you're
beautiful inside and out babe thank you
Schrader I really do and facing the time
outs taught to me ain't sure nice it's
because I think even was what you were
saying about being in the school
playground freckles like that's
happening to someone out there yeah and
it's great that they can look up to you
and be like oh my god when I get to that
age I'm gonna feel powerful I'm gonna
feel empowered yeah
rapping thanks so much you're the best
much more amazing empowering videos like
this with such epic empowering women as
Perry make sure you subscribe to the
glamour UK channels now
[Music]